hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
[Music]
III is fast approaching yet again the
place we keep an eye on to plan out our
future purchases and get hyped for the
year ahead this year will likely be a
little strange as my playstation
brothers and sisters will not be there
so no updates on the ghosts of Tsushima
death stranding or even the Last of Us
part two instead we will focus on the
third parties so I've gone through all
the rumors and speculation to find 15
games to look forward to at e3 2019
before we start let's see what you guys
are most excited for right your most
anticipated game in the comments below
and like the games you can't wait to
play anyway if you're ready let's do
this we have to start with the one game
which has received universal praise from
everyone who saw it behind closed doors
one year ago cyberpunk 2077 in
development for over six years now
cyberpunk 2077 will be a massive
role-playing game set in the futuristic
streets of night city the inhabitants
are surrounded by high levels of
Technology but also the seedy underbelly
of crime and villainy are also on the
rise so poverty crossed with technology
the developers CD Projekt RED have a
track record of excellence but above all
else integrity no hidden costs no anti
consumer decisions no releasing a game
before it's finished real integrity I'm
expecting a playable demo this year and
more importantly a release date believe
me when I say cyberpunk 2077 is a huge
deal I'll link a video which breaks down
the game and setting in a little more
depth do you remember the Splinter Cell
series yeah they are starting to fade
from memory aren't they which makes 2019
the perfect time to bring back some
Fisher and his stealth combat skills
recently a lead developer accidentally
let slip he was working on the next
splinter cell game and what better place
to officially reveal Sam's return than
e3 Sam Fisher pops up in Ghost Recon
wildlands last year
voiced by his og voice actor Michael
on site who had a minor falling-out with
Ubisoft so if he's back fingers crossed
Splinter Cell must be back to recently
respawn entertainment revealed a game
they are working on and it's a bloody
big one Star Wars Jedi fallen order
fallen order stars a young survivor of
order 66 as he finds his feet as a Jedi
this will be a solo campaign focused
picking up right after the events of
Revenge of the Sith tying into the
movies and the law the combat will focus
on up-close melee action but as yet we
haven't seen his lightsaber I have a
sneaking suspicion it will be pinky
excited for this one let me know your
thoughts The Walking Dead games have
been a bit of a mixed bag the early
brilliance of lien Clementine in the
tell tale series but also the way that
series fell apart and the similar thing
happened to Overkill's version of the
game so is the Walking Dead a poisoned
chalice in the video game world we won't
need to wait very long to find out as
The Walking Dead onslaught is on the way
we don't know very much at this point
but we have been told that we will play
as Rick Grimes the messed up hero he as
to us all the press release tells us we
can expect visceral real motion melee
combat so zombie murdering confirmed we
shall see what e3 brings over the last
year the hype behind a superhero game
has gained traction codenamed the
Avengers project was first revealed in
2017 but then it completely vanished not
a single piece of information since with
e3 2019 rolling up on us I'm almost
certain Square Enix will not want to
miss another chance to read reveal the
Avengers project on the largest stage of
them all like I say we don't have a clue
what it's going to be like so what do
you think the Avengers project will be
the wait is killing me did you ever play
Dragon Age origin for many people it was
one of the greatest games of all time a
fantasy role-playing game with
storytelling and finesse
years beyond this ps3 release three
games and fourteen DLCs later and it's
now time for Dragon Age for the dead
wolf Rises there is more worried than
hype surrounding Dragon Age 4 due to the
developers of the game Bioware and the
fall from grace going from top-tier game
creation to well to anthem people move
on companies change is this the same
Bioware I hope so let's see what Dragon
Age bar becomes earlier this year
Resident Evil 2 remake was released and
it was a masterpiece reimagining Claire
and Leon survival against the undead in
a hyper realistic world easily one of
the games of the year for 2019 around
the police station we found evidence of
another character from the timeline that
character was none other than the
Nemesis from Resident Evil three
immediately we all knew that resident
evil 3 nemesis remake must be coming
soon but will Capcom reveal it this year
or next year to play as the og hero Jill
Valentine constantly in fear of the
Nemesis sounds like hell on earth I
can't wait to play back in 2015
Final Fantasy 7 remake was revealed and
exclusive for ps4 infusing the
old-school brilliance of the ps1
original with the real-time action of
Kingdom Hearts 3 this was going to be
epic but then development slowed down to
a crawl and PlayStation stopped
reporting on it so I looked into it and
found that Square Enix has now taken the
project in-house and placed it firmly
behind closed doors moving the Kingdom
has three team on to the Final Fantasy 7
project III 2019 will see the release of
the remake heavily speculated to be
episodic I'm not sure how I feel about
that business model what do you say
ready to revisit Final Fantasy 7 only
one week before I'm writing this and
Ubisoft have decided to reveal Ghost
Recon break point before e3 the game is
set to build on Ghost Recon wildlands an
open-world behind enemy lines
cooperative shooter this time we will
fight other specop agents turned rogue
likely this will feed into the
multiplayer portion hopefully allowing
us to jump into other people's games and
attack them from the shadows if that's
true expect lots of trolling Ghost Recon
breakpoint also introduces the injury
system and stamina to which take the
game into new areas of realism and
survival this could be Shon redefining
and guess what it's coming out this year
October 4th
to be precise another game receiving a
sequel in the coming
is beyond good and evil first released
in 2004 on the ps2 the game wasn't a
huge success but a firm fan favorite
due to the story and blending of genres
now in 2019 Beyond Good and Evil 2 has
well wow wow blown the visuals out of
the water just just look at it it's
bloody gorgeous
what's ultra cool about Beyond Good and
Evil 2 is the company hit record an open
source creative sharing platform which
has been tasked to create visuals and
sound for the game so if you want your
work to be in the game get involved it's
that simple truly revolutionary Beyond
Good and Evil 2 will be an adventure
role-playing game with hoverbikes
egyptian-style futures and random things
that shouldn't be seen together but my
work they do look good remember apex
legends it was once thought to battle
fortnight for the control of the worlds
but sadly it stagnated and everyone
except the hardcore moved on well EA and
respawn want to get apex legends back on
our radar through season 2 of their
battle puss season 1 was underwhelming
and the lack of updates haven't helped
either but at its core apex Legends is
excellent all it needs is a shot in the
arm and maybe season 2 will do that if
you play apex legends every week would
you write it in the comments below
please I'm really interested to see if
anyone in this audience still plays that
game for the past three years I've ended
this list with a plea to gearbox begging
them to reveal Borderlands 3 and
hallelujah it happened last month I was
even there in the first group to play
the game I don't know why I included
that humblebrag my apologies well at e3
2019 Borderlands 3 will reveal endgame
content modern gaming insists that games
are a service these days and shouldn't
be shelved after completing them so how
will Borderlands 3 stay relevant months
after its release I'm looking forward to
seeing what happens after the credits
roll if you want to see me play
Borderlands 3 for the first time I'll
link it now
so the last three games on the list
cannot be backed up in the slightest
only spoken rumors without any real
links to stories but hey rumors are
rumors and some of these are damn good
firstly remember at the start when I
said no PlayStation involvement well I
can't help but feel like Sony need to
reveal something maybe gameplay from the
Last of Us part two maybe a ghost of
Tsushima feature act or another update
on the world's most unfathomable game
death stranding it's important for Sony
to let people know they are a power to
be reckoned with at this time of year
they don't have to be at e3 but maybe
they should reveal something within that
week as we've already talked about
Ubisoft let's talk about watchdogs 3
it's been three years since the last
entry and the Internet is rife with
watchdogs 3 news supposedly the new game
will be set in London I can't wait to
hear the accents there's two which
always pop up there's the wolf will Lara
Croft voice hello Tarquin how are you
today oh there's the cockney gangsters
you love you hopefully both will be in
the game interestingly the main
character will be female okay I have no
idea why that's interesting but the
internet says it is as long as she's
about us I couldn't care less
also of note is that the gun laws in the
UK may see watchdogs change a little as
shootings are very uncommon here so
maybe melee weapons will take center
stage and as we all know we all carry
around three-foot knives to stab each
other all the time
I mean stereotypes embrace them I
suppose
and finally Rockstar Games the
brilliance of Red Dead Redemption 2 has
just about got away from us they're once
again trying to put the online portion
in a better place but overall what is
their focus going forward could we see a
GTA 6 confirmation or maybe it's finally
time to see bully 2 made bully was like
a smaller version of GTA focused around
academic life in a boarding school Jimmy
was the playable character who was
bullet he did some bullying and he also
tried to find love with girls far too
tall for him and was up to enough
mischief that Loki would be proud of him
it was also pretty good at throwing
fists what do you think bully - will it
ever be made
so there we have it 15 games to keep an
eye out for at t3 2019 what the top of
your list cyberpunk 2077 right anyway
it's been a pleasure thank you very much
for your time come talk to me on Twitter
by the way I'm Adam grenade over there
anyway it's been a pleasure I'll see you
soon
[Music]